each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hi are we are very happy to have with us
today for a shell from the fraunhofer
Center in Maryland so forest is actually
one of Vic bacilli students and he got
his PhD from the University of Maryland
prior to that he was at Loyola College
in Maryland to forest is a division
director of the knowledge management
division at fraunhofer he's going to
talk to us today about some of his work
on building bodies of knowledge in
software development processes thanks
Nancy okay so as not she said that the
talk i went to give today is about the
idea of building up bodies of knowledge
about practices a lot of the work I've
been doing over the last 10 12 years or
so I guess has been empirically studying
how do we get an understanding of how
effective or how costly or what kind of
defects various practices that we can
use for software development might be
and I think as a community the empirical
software community has been pretty good
I think about improving ourselves over
time running case studies running
controlled experiments that help us get
insight into these things but the next
frontier if you will for the community
is how do we put these studies together
in order so that we can say something
robust and useful about these practices
in a lot of different circumstances so a
lot of what I've been doing is really
been driven by how can we communicate
you know some of these neat studies that
we're doing in the labs that we publish
in the research papers how do we really
communicate interesting findings from
these out to the to the engineers that
can use them and really find the results
interesting and hopefully make decisions
based on them so the way I realized I
should have motivated this talk a little
differently so let me back up and say
the reason I started to put these slides
together is that in 2003 Congress issued
a directive to the Department of Defense
that they needed to have a central
clearinghouse that they called it so
that they could recommend practices for
software engineers for software
acquisition professionals and for system
engineers
that they could recommend practices and
have the evidence behind them and so
that you could make recommendations that
you could choose the right practices for
your project based on an evidence-based
approach rather than your gut feeling or
instinct or or vendors DoD came to us to
help them figure out how to do this
request and so the the work that we've
done here is really driven by how can we
come up with a system for the DoD that
can make some of these recommendations
available and useful if the people can
come and understand what's the evidence
for various practices and where they're
going to work okay so to do that what I
want to do is put some motivating slides
together obviously the work that I've
done is then in software engineering and
so most of the examples here in a
software flavor and what I wanted to
talk about was a couple different
methodology logical things that we've
learned from trying to abstract
conclusions across bodies of knowledge
so I'm going to put a couple of
different studies up here on different
topics and I hope you'll forgive me a
little bit because I'm going to jump
from topic to topic but the important
thing here is really the methodology and
how we're trying to put them together so
to give you a sense of why this is hard
first I'll talk in a little bit more
detail than some of the others about
software inspections in the body of
knowledge there what kind of studies are
out there how they fit together then
I'll switch gears a little bit and say
well we've tried to do it better by
designing studies are priori to fit
together we did that in the area of high
performance computing so i'll give you
an insight into what we did there and
then i'll briefly mention some other
more rigorous techniques that folks have
used for looking at requirements
engineering techniques and for pair
programming okay and then i'll come back
at the end and say well what if we
learned from these studies that helped
us to build the system and i'll show you
where we are there and give you some
kind of lessons learned that as we've
gone forward with building the system
we've learned from the from the
practitioners that are going to be using
it okay so first just a bit about me
actually not she gave me a nice
introduction so I won't say too much I
did get my PhD in 98 with Vic as my
advisor in 99 I moved to the fraunhofer
Center Maryland it's a little it's a
small company maybe 24 people all
together it's a non-profit we're
affiliated with the University of
Maryland and our mandate is tech
transfer and so what we try and do is
sit in between the universities of the
developing nifty new software
development techniques and the folks in
commercial sites or government sites
that should be applying them and we try
and bridge that that gap a little bit
better i mentioned that just because
you'll notice that there's I think a lot
of tech transfer types of things in the
talk I hope we've really been kind of
wrestling with how we do good research
and then make it accessible for the for
the engineers currently I'm division
director for measurement and knowledge
management we've done a lot of research
grants we've worked for NSF NASA's
Office of safety and mission assurance
DARPA we've worked with teams at NASA
fujitsu Defense Department a lot of
other places actually trying to get them
to use the technologies trying to
understand how well the technologies
work in their environments worked on a
lot of different topics and I'm also I
just want to put a little plug here for
the last couple months I've been writing
a column for I tripoli software magazine
which is trying to do exactly this you
look across the body of knowledge make
it accessible for practitioners I've
been trying out a couple of different
ideas there and so if people have a
chance to take a look and give me some
feedback as to how were how we're going
as we build this column it would be
something I'd I would find very valuable
okay so just one slide is a brief
introduction to empirical software
engineering this if you've seen talks
from other empirical software engineers
this probably looks familiar because
it's one slide that we've come up with
the kind of encapsulates our basic
approach to life at heart what we're
trying to do is apply the scientific
method to reasoning about software
engineering practices and that means
that we're trying to take a look at
observing understanding and how people
actually use the things and what we can
measure what we can learn about how
effective or not they are building
models to try and encapsulate the
knowledge and make it useful
experimenting so if we have an idea how
we might improve it we introduce it in a
controlled way we do further measurement
to see if we actually made an
improvement or not and then hopefully
evolving you know that as we learn more
things we try and have an effect on the
practice and then we iterate because
then this evolution becomes the next
baseline okay and we try and understand
now what's there how we could improve
what kind of depending on the topic what
kind of defects we're catching you know
basically we don't
we'd like to work with quantitative data
most of us but we also look at
qualitative things doing surveys
interviews with folks in the field and
really what we need for this is real
world laboratories so this is not an
approach that you can really work with
at the University kind of cut off from
the rest of the world but we do get out
there and really try and work with the
engineers that can that are out there in
the field that can give us the
information we need they can help us to
understand what's really what's really
going on with these techniques so some
of the points I'd like to make and hope
you'll take away before the end of the
presentation there's no
one-size-fits-all solutions in software
engineering is one of my deep and
abiding beliefs even if there's things
that work for most teams like for
example independent reviews I think of
coming in and taking an independent look
at the technical work you're doing I I
think we can't actually go out there and
say that's going to work for a hundred
percent of the teams you know teams that
are on a tight budget or they're doing
rapid prototyping and yeah there's no
solution out there that's going to be
recommended for everybody a lot of what
I'm going to talk about relies on
measurement and even though it's not
perfect you know there's a lot of
troubles when we try and measure things
in the field when people have time
constraints when it's people that are
applying the technologies it gets very
difficult but some information is better
than none and we think we have a good
way of getting some of this out that
measurement can aid technology transfer
a lot of what we do relies on looking at
things in controlled situations in the
first place understanding using
measurement to help us understand
whether they're good or not and then
growing it helping it deploy from there
that if i want to make real practical
decisions if i want to you know advocate
different techniques for use in
different places I really need robust
data sets which means I need more than
one study I really need a body of
information that I can put together and
abstract some conclusions from and
finally there's not perfect techniques
and I'll show you some of the ways we're
trying to struggle to get ahold of this
but effective techniques that exist for
helping me do those abstractions so the
first example is software inspections
this is just a brief graph so that we
all understand what I mean when I talk
about inspection
I have some artifact that I want to get
defects out of I come in and do a
planning phase I have to figure out
what's the right part of the artifact
inspect to or the right people to do it
hand it off to a number of different
inspectors that go look for defects we
come together as a team and collect them
and then finally the author goes back
and fixes the things we agree need to be
fixed okay there's been a lot of
research work and measurement on
software inspections over time the work
that I've done particularly is how do we
improve this step here so I have an
artifact I throw it off to a bunch of
new smart technical guys can I give them
some better guidance as to how they're
going to find the defects as to how they
can actually get a handle on whether or
not this is a high-quality document or
not okay so the work that I want to talk
about what I tried to do is organize
some of it a little graphically
challenge there with me please but what
I tried to do here was each box is to
study I had to label them somehow so if
you really want at the end of the talk
there's a bunch of slides that say which
studies is all reference I organize them
by whether their requirements design or
code artifacts that we looked at and
then this is time you know so this is
earlier and then studies that come later
over to the right somewhere this is not
to say we think that there has to be a
waterfall lifecycle I'm just trying to
divide up the world of possibilities
here okay so taking a quick look across
the body of knowledge a lot of the
research on the reading techniques got
kicked off by ABBA study back here by
bazillion selby in 87 which they did at
the University of Maryland they had
professionals from NASA Goddard a bunch
of graduate students there and they
asked him for three different pieces of
code to apply functional testing
structural testing and code reading
interestingly for the professionals code
reading came out on top actually found
the most defects in the least amount of
time functionally structural test were
about equal it wasn't a big difference
there but for the students and it didn't
really matter which one they did they
weren't doing a you know a better job
with one technique or the other anyway
okay so at least this let us say well
reading is actually an effective way of
getting defects out you know by doing
reading I did better than actually
relying on tests to find the defects you
know there's a problem with the students
here maybe it's a motivational problem
you know the students are just doing
this kind of weird offline little
experiment we need a weight
get them to do a better job okay next
thing they looked at is taking that idea
and then said okay let's take this to
the extreme so let's have a bunch of
developers that can do nothing but code
reading okay they call this the clean
room approach so what they found when I
compared clean room teams two teams that
could develop code and then test it
before handing it off to the next guy
cleanroom teams actually did much better
they met more of the functional
requirements they met their intermediate
deadlines but then interestingly you
know eighty-six percent of those guys
that oh maybe it was more effective but
this is really an unnatural way of
developing software you know I really
hate the fact that i'm coding way and i
can't compile it at the end of the day i
can't test the darn thing so you know
there was a good research results but
the actual engineers in the study were
complaining abit but you know let's just
say well you know there's something to
this reading thing you know we can get
good results here if we just look at
defect numbers there's some kind of a
cultural shift that has to go along we
need a better handle on that you know
but it's promising so the next study
they took this clean room idea and then
piloted it at NASA Goddard so this paper
here this facility 97 actually talks
about a series of four studies first
year they did a pilot project where
folks on a real development project
could only use clean room and they
modified it a little bit so you could do
some compilation and then unit testing
before you had to hand it off to someone
else to test your stuff so that
mollified the the the coders a little
bit their textures that's exactly the
reasoning I mean that so that the not
allowing them to compile it was I think
too extreme but then you get to the next
level where you're saying well you know
you can do some unit code yeah some unit
testing I'm sorry that was the more
important point there oh so this goes to
you know the empirical method I mean how
do you know so clean room in some sense
is a whole bunch of little ideas bundled
together right how do you know what to
attribute the effect two so for example
it could have been a psychological
effect if I'm not even allowed compile
Mike though I could be so paranoid about
errors but I'm just in a very
attentive place when I write the code
right whereas if you give if you love me
to compile it suddenly there's the
psychological crotch that oh the
compiler will catch my bottoms right so
that could have been the critical
ingredient success of clean room and now
you know right that's it that's a very
good thing right usually we say we say a
little bit more positively that you know
I am in a way I know someone else is
going to be testing the code I don't
want to be embarrassed you know sorry
I'm going to do a better job you know
kind of going through line by line you
using human reasoning at you know in a
better way to make sure the algorithm is
actually correct to make sure the thing
is there and I'm not going to get dinged
with a lot of stupid defects and when I
hand it off to to someone else the test
but so what that's exactly the point
though and what you'll see is that what
we did was then took a piece of it in
these later studies and tried to test it
individually to say as this really is
this reading idea really the idea or is
it just that you know we're in an
experimental context we have a Hawthorne
effect you know I want this to work out
or like you said I'm afraid of failure
and so I'm going to really you know go
to an unnatural lengths to really get
the defects out let's say so we're yes
so in the Nazca context again we saw a
reduced failure rate the folks are a
little bit happier they could do the
unit testing they were more productive
more productive but the interesting
thing is then when they took a look at
the defects people were getting out it
was all over the place you know so
people could look at the same code and
find completely different sets of
defects which makes you think that laser
made those cut those guys think you know
that reading seems to be a good way to
do this so it's an effective approach
it's getting the defects but I'm a
little nervous that it's such an
uncontrolled mechanism here that how do
I have any kind of guarantee that people
are going to find that all the defects
that are there if everyone's kind of all
over the map which leads us to this next
study and this is where now I got
involved this was part of my
dissertation actually back in whenever
this was 97 I guess what we did was
exactly that we stripped away the rest
of the clean room stuff we took out the
code reading idea and I'll show you in
just a minute how we set up the
experiment but here what we found was
that the inspections when I had the
excuse me of it and I had a more
tailored reading technique you know what
we tried to do was get some control over
it give people a much more procedural
way to actually go through and do the
defect
detection and then see if that actually
maybe the improvement or not and what we
found there was for most of the
situation's we looked at the structured
reading found more defects than when I
did it without that they're from code to
requirements documents right so can you
say a little bit more about what you
were actually doing with the documents
and what they were what's the substitute
for code here I mean yes so what we had
it for the the master project we were
working with what they had bird natural
language english requirements you know
so it was a bunch of the software shall
the software shall that kind of issue so
we picked up what we found was that even
though they were using the clean room
thing here the clean room approach most
of the defects that NASA was worrying
about we're not actually at the coding
level yeah I think time and again what
we found is that by the time i get to
coding i have a bunch of good coders i
can do a good job with it yes there's
defects we have to worry about but the
real things that tended to trip them up
work we're bad requirements they had
design documents and so what we were
trying to say was well you we have some
idea from these studies that this
inspection reading idea looks like a
good thing let's see if we can pick up
the core piece of it you know the idea
that we can ask people to read in a
structured way give them a procedure for
looking through that document and that
we can give them a different that we can
try and control this the fact that the
finding defects all over the place by
giving them a specific perspective at
the same time and apply that to the to
the requirements documents that were
there so what we had we did this twice
we had 25 experienced developers from
NASA both times and again what we asked
them to do is we gave them a very
procedural approach we're looking
through the document to find defects you
know we had basically came up with this
idea of three-person teams where each
person on the team takes a different
stakeholders point of view so someone's
going to be a design or someone's going
to pretend they're a tester someone's
going to be a user so i can constrain
them a little bit you know they don't
have to worry about finding every defect
out there in the world you know but at
the same time they have a very more
specific focus of what to look for we
gave them we had four different
requirements documents that we looked at
in any experiment two that were pieces
of real things from NASA to that we're
more generic
we had used at the University so an ATM
in a parking garage system basically and
each of these had seeded defects in it
some of which we we put in there some of
which we knew they had been put in as as
people were developing the documents in
the in the first place and then what we
were looking at was trying to measure
the defect detection rate so how many of
those defects that we know we're out
there are people actually going to go
find okay the study that we did this was
part of a training course and so we were
able to get the NASA folks for this that
way we gave them a bit of training first
often defect types and we went to have a
baseline that everyone's out there
looking for the same types of things so
we don't want to bias the study one way
or the other that way we asked them to
use their usual approach for reviewing
advanced a document we asked them to use
their usual approach for reviewing one
of these generic guys then we gave them
training in the reading technique and
then ask them again look at a generic
document look at the nasa document so
for each person we could see what was
the improvement on each of these topics
from the before training to the after
training okay so was in it was a within
within subject study now the problem was
we didn't have really any much faith
about how difficult these documents were
to look at so we were afraid we could
easily bias the study if we put all the
easy documents here and all the hard
ones up here so and what we ended up
doing was dividing the folks into you
know so some of them looked at the the B
documents for some of them with the VA
documents first and then they all
switched and what we found so again we
did this twice so here's what we found
on the generic documents and in the nasa
document in the first study and then the
generic and the nasa documents in the
second one and what you can see is it
for the generic documents the teams were
finding many more defects with the peat
with the reading technique than they
were with the usual one for the generic
ones only I mean there's a there's a bit
of a jump here and a bit of a jump from
48 to 60 to over there with the NASA
documents they're not so much I mean
here there was really nothing this was
not at all signal assista kelis ignition
of course and then in the 95 study they
had done a little better but it still
wasn't within the realm of being
statistically significant so what we
took away from this was that again the
reading seems to work fine under
and circumstances but not the others we
went back and did a series of structured
interviews with the subjects after the
fact and what we found was at least an
indication that because we had given
them a set amount of time to go read
through the documents and find the
defects that when they had something
that looked like what they saw in a
normal daily basis and they had a time
limit they kind of fell back on what
they knew was going to be effective
anyway so we gave them a nice procedural
technique they said gee that's great but
I only have an hour to review the
document or whatever it was so they kind
of put that aside and went into what
they normally did anyway and so you can
see it doesn't really make much much
difference whether we thought they were
using usual or we thought they were
using reading because in the end they
were really doing more or less the same
thing both times the conclusion we draw
from that was that when i'm looking at
something where i don't have much
familiarity when I don't have as much
experience about the types of defects
that are out there and the and I need a
crutch to rely on then if I give you
some procedural guy and said it will
actually be helpful exactly the
temperately what you got used to project
what we what we ended up wanting to do
was it if we can interview these the
more experienced folks and take their
knowledge and put it back into the the
more procedural guidance then exactly
what you said we could give it to the
new guys on the team they need the
crutch you know we'd like to you know
they can benefit from the experience of
the more more people who were more used
to these types of documents these types
of reviews and then as I get better
either I don't really need that guidance
anymore or better yet I can try and keep
it updated so that we as a team have a
little bit of a you know a mini
knowledge repository for example that
what it makes sense to look for what
kind of defects come up over time
and I'm standing a little trouble with
with does an inclusion that technique is
effectively you know people don't
actually want to apply because their
perception is that it's not going to
help and only in circumstances whether
it probably had seen today today fall
back on typically you would want more
experienced people reviewing your
requirement you know how many experts
again an expert what we're dealing with
here was a situation at NASA where they
you know would have loved to get these
experienced people on the team but the
experience people were few and far
between and they're being asked to
review just about every darn thing so
the question was well how can we unload
some of that workload from them you know
so the more hopeful takeaway here I
think was that if we could kind of
capture some of that knowledge and put
it so that we could bring the more
inexperienced people up a little bit of
a level we could share the workload
around we don't have to rely on those
experienced people all the time I think
that what you're saying is exactly right
that we would never say that we're
coming up with a substitute for the
experienced people you know that we can
take an inexperienced guy and make them
just as good as those experienced folks
but rather I think we'd like to approach
this from the point of view of saying
the experience folks are valuable assets
and we would like to learn from them and
pull that into the procedural technique
inexperienced and unfamiliar because I
should know these people were not all
experienced new hires but they were
unfamiliar with the generic doc yes so
you know can you can you separate out
the two ah well we certainly tried I
mean we went back and we looked at now
we didn't give them a pretest so we
really couldn't say anything about what
their effectiveness was coming into this
unfortunately
we had some idea of how long they were
there and we we asked them how long they
had been at NASA how long they had been
doing this type of work in a cent and
how many inspections they had been on
and what we found was that none of those
things allow this project who was going
to do a good job in New not yeah so we
were we were a bit disappointed at that
but what we did see again again maybe
one of the things to look at here also
is that when they did a good job so
these are our Venn diagrams so I tried
to take all the defects that they found
so two of those defects were found only
by designers three were found only by
the users 5 by the testers and there
were four that were found by someone
from all those different perspectives so
when the when they reading inspection
techniques actually had to win you could
see that there was things out here in
the in the leaves you know so that some
of these guys were finding things that
the other stakeholders were not finding
it all and then when I put them together
on the team they did a much better job
of getting coverage out there the cases
where there wasn't any benefit to the
reading you can see this one the numbers
are just low all over this one all the
numbers end up in this overlap here you
know so people are kind of doing the
same thing again I think you know
they're out there looking for defects
they're just finding the easy ones
perhaps and that's why we're seeing all
this overlap so what we've been trying
to say since then is you know at least
there's a question about whether the
procedure to what extent the procedure
ilysm really helps you know that's one
of the variables here but for sure what
it seems like is I can do a much better
job if I can give people the unique
stakeholder points of view and I can
bring them together where they're each
not responsible for finding everything
in the document because that just
overwhelms people but they can worry
about a specific slice of it and slice
in a virtual sense meaning things that
are going to be related to my
perspective and then we come together
and we get a win at the team level when
I should also say I didn't show a graph
but we also found that the individual
inspectors did much better here with
with the reading than they did using
their normal approach and again from the
interviews a lot of what seemed to be
coming out of that was you know I have a
smaller focus I don't have to worry
about everything in the world but I just
have to worry about things related to me
and I could ignore parts of it and go
deeper on the the other pieces of the
document
so that from that point of view the
inspectors actually did like the the
perspective based approach at least ok
now that study is actually one of the
probably most replicated studies in
software engineering well at least an
empirical software engineering let me
say and I tried to graph here so these
are the four stages we just looked at
and I've squished them over on the left
side here on the right I tried to put at
least some of the studies that came out
of this work and you can see people took
this idea of the procedural techniques
and then applied it to requirements
documents to design documents to code
documents and the other here was
websites i think website usability ok so
this idea that well there seems to be
some promise here to having a more
focused more procedural reading
technique you know now let's see if we
can take it and apply it in all these
different problem domains and so what we
find actually is that the results were
promising enough as I go forward well I
can color it here but I'm sorry by which
of these were done in the industry and
which in the classroom and what you find
is that when you look just like in here
we have had a nice feature where I tried
something out in the classroom i piloted
that clean room thing at NASA and then
it actually got in use on a number of
different projects I can start to see
that same issue or that same type of
situation coming up again and again so
here was someone who applied the reading
techniques this was a study I was
involved with actually we tried to look
at object-oriented designs someone else
pick this up and applied it to a state
government project in Brazil I think and
then it was actually put in you said
Erickson and Sweden here's another one
where we kept working on these
requirements documents for a while then
we applied it again in a case study at
NASA that was for flight software was
the so3 and then in so4 it actually got
used on inspecting a software that
monitors the electrical power on the
International Space Station now the
difficult thing to see here though is
that I mean the issue you brought up
earlier was correct you know that
there's it's not really a package deal
that there's different pieces of this
that might be causing the benefit and
others now
there's a difficulty that some of these
were case studies like ESO ESO for some
of these were controlled experiments
like the one back here that I showed you
so we can't really just dump all the
data together and say okay look every
time I gave it to these guys to the
perspective based approach to these guys
they did better and every time I ask
these people to do it with their usual
approach they did worse you know I can't
just really make all one big data set
out of it and do that I can't really do
anything really statistically rigorous
where I put these all together and say
well across all these different studies
you know this is always one because that
wasn't actually the case we did see some
of the studies we're reading didn't seem
to work for whatever reason there were
fewer those then then the ones where it
did work though so in general at least
there you you could say well there's
something promising going on here at
least convince people to pick it up try
it out and change their actual practice
based on this but it's a little bit hard
to say well how rigorous is that
conclusion you know this makes a nice
kind of related work section of the
paper but it's really hard to you know
to say how rigorous our conclusion is
here so that was the first example let
me just I'll leave this issue here just
to kind of say a little bit about how
Jesus is a complicated problem trying to
put all this together so having learned
from that experience what we did a
little bit later this was in 2005 we had
a project for DARPA and we tried to
learn from that earlier study not about
the inspections per se but about how we
do it studies in a good way what we
wanted to do here was to look at how we
can how we can build up knowledge about
how productive people are in developing
codes for supercomputers so for doing
high-end computing there is a lot of
work previously that looked at how are
you how I can work in these parallel
environments and get the the execution
time of a program down there hadn't been
a lot of work about well for some of
these solutions that I come up with over
there well how does that impact the the
actual programmers time you know it
might be a very efficient algorithm or a
very efficient way of sending messages
back and forth but Jesus it's so
complicated and imposes so much overhead
that it actually drives up the time it
takes to build the thing and you know
increases the defect rate one might say
so we had a seer
studies you wanted to design based on
this particular type of thing and what
we thought was well maybe we can be a
little bit smarter this time you know
we've seen kind of in an ad hoc way how
these studies can build on each other
with the inspection stuff perhaps we can
try and design a set of studies our
priority that are going to build up
knowledge and we can have a more
rigorous basis for things here okay so
the two variables we had kind of doing
this this meta study in a way we had
different types of studies we could put
together so controlled experiments where
I can look at something in small and get
to a more rigorous answer under
controlled conditions do observational
studies where we actually go into the
field sit with the engineers that are
developing things understand how they do
it you know surveys interviews and focus
groups so trying to collect some kind of
qualitative information from folks
across a larger field case studies and
field studies you know again where we
look at maybe one program and try and
follow it for a longer time and get a
better more rigorous basis for what's
going on there so this was one dimension
in a way the second dimension we had
access to a number of different types of
applications you know so there's a
little classroom assignments that as
people are taught how to develop super
computer codes you know they look at
things like Game of Life parallel
sorting you know so very small problems
just to build up your understanding
going up to compact apps which are
really key benchmarks that folks have
come up with most of these from the
National Labs to try and understand on
different architectures different
programming approaches how well this
solution is going to perform all the way
up to full scientific applications so we
sat with some of the teams the flash
team up at a university of chicago for
example trying to understand how they
are going about a multi-year project
trying to develop you know codes that
predict the performance of supernovas so
what we thought was we need a kind of a
pull yourself up by your bootstraps
approach here okay so we set up to do
some pilot some controlled experiments
in the first place on classroom
assignments that's not really going to
give you the answers you went for the
field it's not a very representative
environment but there was a lot of
things we didn't even understand what
variables we had to be collecting at
that point we didn't understand how hard
it was going to be the instrument the
computers and
some of the data that we were looking
for okay then we SAT and did
observational studies of people actually
doing the classroom assignments trying
to understand at least one on one these
students are trying to learn the
techniques you know how they do it why
we're not getting accurate data or how
accurate the data we're getting is going
up to controlled experiments of
classrooms where we could put other
people within the same class to try and
do the same problem different ways or
people across classes to do it going up
two case studies case studies of the
compact ABS you know interviews with
developers so we were really trying to
start small and build things as we went
ok trying to do this in an intelligent
controlled way and now what we found
here was we could get a set of data out
so what I tried to do here is just put
for one particular question that we had
which is the two approaches that were
very popular for building up codes on
supercomputers one mpi or we have a lot
of control over things and can you know
but it requires a lot of code versus
OpenMP where the compiler handles some
of it for you ok but you have in you
have less code to write so we tried to
look at how those things trade it off so
what I've graphed here is the difference
in programming effort between those two
so each graph what I've done is for each
subject who developed the same
assignment in two different ways I've
subtracted there openmp effort from
their MPI effort okay so if it ended up
at zero that means the two approaches
were more or less equal in terms of the
effort they took things that are above
the line mean that folks took less time
with OpenMP than with mpi and you'll see
that's where most of the data falls out
sure
yes well what we asked well for example
for Game of Life we would take it and
ask someone to do it in MPI first early
in the semester and then do the same
problem and openmp later in the semester
or vice versa so we weren't we weren't
trying to compare across different
problems but we're looking at the same
problems on different ways so MPs
message singing OpenMP assure member yes
paralyzation oh so MP is different in
the two things one yeah yeah I ultimate
star dancing yes and the ice business in
token MP is compiler what does the MP
stem for Vulcan MP process multi-process
oh was that they were both messages now
the naming is bad libraries are horrible
there's lots of things from the single
letters here again we're what I'm sorry
these are just different classes where
we took the class off we don't want to
embarrass anybody in saying this this
data came from MIT versus University of
Maryland or whatever it might be yeah
exactly I'm sure very a lot of people
would have been interested in that maybe
more experiments this is jeff some
people this yes so that each of these is
a different group of persons I think
these are all game of life actually so
I'll say these are the same project done
yes so what we found you know it at one
part it looks like okay well we have a
lot of data it's the same metrics you
maybe we can throw all this together and
do a little bit of a better analysis
across all these studies and before but
you know again what we actually find is
that the procedures the experiment
actually changed enough over time that
we feel really like that you know you
can't just combine all these different
things and this is something because we
do this in an iterative fashion it's
very hard to get people replicating the
same project over and over again where
we could really do a straight comparison
of the same project so here you know
what we found was that people were
learning
see I know let's say OpenMP first in an
MPI later in the semester so I could
look at the the two data points and do
some kind of comparison there but the
problem becomes jeez well yeah if they
learn MPI later and semester they're a
lot smarter at that point than they were
coming in the door so is that really a
fair comparison but what we had to do
was live within the constraints of what
people were doing in the classrooms and
how they were giving the assignments out
so we kind of lived with it for a while
after a while we build up more trust
with the instructors I think that was a
positive thing and we tried to control
for ordering so what we asked them to do
was to teach both approaches first off
you know teach openmp teach of MPI and
then let people do it in either order so
all day there wasn't any intermediate
deadlines but you learned the approaches
then you had hand in both solutions at
the end and whatever happened in the
meantime was was not any concern of ours
and what you see here is that suddenly
the data is all over the map so this is
from an experimental point of view it's
not particularly great for us you know
the the the variation between the two
suddenly went way kablooey so then what
we try to do is to come back and control
it a little bit better again where we
could teach the two approaches half the
class got the openmp version of the
assignment half the class got the NPI
and then they switched did the outdid
each other's thing and came back at the
end with both solutions so here finally
we're getting some proper control for
ordering so if I look at these things I
don't want to throw them all together
because in a way they're not all equally
trustable if you will so hopefully going
forward now we can build up a body of
knowledge where I can put these all
together in one dataset you know make
the argument that they're equally valid
in some way and i can analyze across
studies but trying to put the whole data
set together is a little bit dangerous
at this point so again in the switch
gears for a minute but just trying to
give you some ideas of the difficulties
that we faced over time trying to build
up bodies of knowledge across studies oh
the good news i think is at least the
experiments at the end we're better than
the ones we started with so we've we've
learned something as experimenters at
least because
there's less variation or it's more
statistical significance or looks you're
not reduction of better okay yeah well
that's a good point actually I mean
there's two notions a better when is
that the variation is down so when I
look at the data I can think okay
there's something I can understand a
little bit better that there's a real
effect here you know that it's not just
the people are all over the all over the
place but secondly looking at it from
the point of view of the experimentation
whether the experiment we ran had the
capability of introducing biases or
throwing off the data these experiments
were much better than these back here
you know what we want to do is rule out
any potential alternate explanation for
the data let's say yeah so going forward
you could say well this is these I'm not
gonna trust any of this data someone
could say because you know they learn to
mpi later on so they were smarter they
had the leg out last this was they
learned both of the approaches first up
but then someone had someone said okay
you have to do the openmp solution and
you can do the MPI one and then a week
for now you hand those in and we give
each of you the opposite assignment okay
so you know we do have these
difficulties since we're dealing with
human subjects all the time we have to
worry about these types of things with
the experimentation okay so let me
switch gears here again and talk about
two other studies really quickly that
tried to handle the same problem and
these were not particular work that I
did with the analysis I just wanted to
call them out as examples here so here's
the citation this was work that some
folks since at the University of Madrid
had been looking at what we can learn
about requirements elicitation
techniques you know so what kind of
techniques I have for sitting with the
customer trying to understand what they
really want the software in the system
to do in the end they looked at well
what they did was look across all the
studies that could find that met their
criteria so they came up with 30 studies
that spanned 20 years of research and
the hope was well across all these 30
studies we could say something surely
about which techniques were better in
which worse why it became difficult Bell
was well when you broke down these 30
studies are actually looking at 43
different techniques yes there was a
number of different flavors of doing
interviews there was things like card
sorting
where I tried to put different
components of the of the system on cars
and arrange them as to which ones go
together in which things are related and
then when I tried to put them together
even at that level you know they're
looking at 50 different variables so
people might have said well we looked at
whether or not one approach required
less time than the other but really one
study looked at how much time it was
start to finish another study looked at
how much time it was to sit as a group
and sort things out another study looked
at how much time it was to sit with the
customer and sort things out so what
they did they took an approach more
similar to vote counting actually so the
little bit of a dangerous thing here is
they tried to abstract things together
so rather than 43 different techniques
let's look at seven different types of
things so let's take all of our
interview techniques and put them
together in one pile let's take all the
contrived techniques or they're building
some kind of strange marble put them
together in another pile and rather than
look at 50 different variables let's say
all these guys were looking at some
measure of you know of time for examples
let's put all those together all these
guys are looking at some measure of how
many requirements you came up with let's
put all those together so there's some
dangerous here I mean for you could
think very easily about that example
with the different time measures you
know if one study said we reduce the
amount of time the people required to
sit with the customer and yet they may
have easily really increased the amount
of time that I had to spend to do the
whole darn yeah process from start to
finish but I don't really have that so
in my data said it looks like they
reduced the time but I don't know if
that's really you know the fair
statement about the study or not but at
least what they were able to get out you
know where some findings at least of the
level of from a rule of thumb or a
heuristic level you know what they found
was in that interview category the
interviews tended to do much better than
any of the other approaches whichever
type of interview I was looking at at
getting the the right number of Eric
getting a a number of requirements there
that Rio that that were I don't say this
they got they got the the most
requirements that were deemed to be
valid by the users of the system when
they evaluated them you know I could
look at other types of techniques you
sorting where I have different
components I try and sort them all out
to tell you how the what are the
components of the system and how they
fit together tended to be much less
effective than most of the other ones
yeah introspective ones where I sit down
and really talk through the problem with
the person and get them to give me a lot
of information about how they would
solve a problem again tended to be less
effective solely you know there's rules
of thumbs here at least we can say well
most of the projects that we've been
talking to are using interviews out in
the field well I think there's a good
reason for that actually I mean if you
look at the data there's no we can at
least say there's no study that should
have gone the other way that told me
that interviews were less effective than
the other alternatives i had so again
here's this is another approach again
has its dangers has its benefits though
and then finally i'll leave with one
example that talks about geez haven't we
ever been able to put data together
across studies in one quantitative pot
and do some analysis against it and when
i found is exactly one study where they
were able to do that and what they did
was look at pair programming which has
been a fairly hot topic in the
experimental community for the last
several years the authors found 15
studies over 10 years where they were
trying to compare pair programming to
doing it without pairs and trying to
figure out what the the solution was
people were using the same metrics of
course you know the the they looked at
different problems and so they would say
the magnitude of the metrics was
different yeah so what they did was try
and normalize it according to the
standard deviation within the data set
so if I give you a number like you know
this study showed a 0.5 that means that
um the mean of the pair's is half of
standard deviation larger than the mean
of the individuals so whatever the exact
values were I can at least tell you
relative to each other where those two
the two groups work out and then what
they could do is coming back to that
idea is is variance and indicator that
something's a little wonky there they
took that same approach and assigned
each study await so if I had a larger
variance it said to me that there's
something more dangerous going on out
there so I'm not going to trust that
study as much and they were able to get
a really nice chart that looks like this
you know so for quality now there's
different studies in each one because
even within those two
teen studies not everyone looked at
quality metrics for example but ever the
ones that did they could put this all
together and say well the mean for the
whole thing was that the quality of pair
programming was you know X standard
deviations bigger than the quality for
solo programming the nice thing about
looking at the forest graph like this as
you can see you know the whole dataset
average was here and you can see each of
the individual studies and where did
they really end up contributing to that
some of these guys so everyone was
here's the zero point so all the studies
showed that the mean was favoring pair
programming you can see for the some of
them the confidence interval kind of
extends the other way but for most of
them you know there's a fairly you have
I want to say there's a pattern that
emerges right that all these studies are
favoring pair programming not by a heck
of a lot that on the other hand
attentively different measures that have
been normalized in some way so that they
can appear together for these it was
actually these roll I think number of
defects i want to say the duration was
all calendar time so the for once
actually we were able to find an example
you know where there's a number of
studies out there in the field that
measure the same thing okay so in an
effort was obviously just person effort
okay yeah so the results you're
interesting though I think you know the
quality you show a little bit better
quality for the pair of programming
actually might have expected it to be
better you know with someone looking
over your shoulder all the time you
might have thought that you know one
that both of us would do a better job
but yeah the ninety-five percent
confidence interval for that study yes
well you can't wait you can see is that
the ones that are huge the size of this
block shows how much weight was given to
that study ok so we smaller husband some
people's instinct and we're just friends
exactly yes I mean it which is an
assumption it the nice thing at least of
having the quantitative data is you
could throw the data back in the pot and
run it differently yeah I could say I
trust them all equally or some of them I
just want to remove from the data center
this formula is the size of the scene
experiments nothing it was certainly
related to the way the experiment was
conducted I don't think offhand I looked
at whether not related to the number of
subjects as in the end of the study and
so is their way of some way to do some
sort of sensitivity analysis to figure
out you know this weighting scheme if
you were to do it completely differently
would you get flip flop of the results
or does it just wiggle a little bit
depending on your weight them ah that's
you know I haven't thought of that
actually but that's an excellent
question offhand that's a the quality
all the center's are sure to the Russia
I guess duration the same after on the
center school at least for quality for
the other tutor there are sorta more of
a mix it here then but the trembles but
I'm wondering if there's some
statistical technique for showing that
it doesn't actually matter what you're
waiting scheme is or it doesn't matter
much or something yeah yeah yeah I
needed for starters I could imagine that
we just give each of them in equal
weight you throw away this idea of
weighting it by the confidence interval
and then seeing if it really much with
the with the answer at all right I
didn't think to do that that's an
excellent thought so anyway I know I've
kind of skipped all over the world here
and I apologize for that but what I was
trying to show was coming back to this
idea of how do we put together a body of
evidence you know that would allow me to
say that this technique is going to be
good for certain things and this other
one not given so many of these
difficulties that I've shown here sure
it seems like part of what made this
exercise particularly nice compared with
some of the previous ones really clean
maybe some of the other ones show this
is that there was so much more agreement
between the different experiments right
exactly is that does that represent a
kind of maturity process of the ESC feel
that meanness they're just getting to be
more agreement over time so these
meta-analyses are easier to do that I
think that that's part of it actually I
mean I think that in the beginning there
is a real bias against replicating
someone else to study you know because
it's just in some ways it's not as much
exactly exactly
so I think that we're seeing within the
experimental software engineering
community some of that going away and I
think also the effect that we're seeing
here is that pair programming was just
such a hot topic you know that even if
people weren't aware of each other
studies they might have all kind of
conglomerated on this particular topic
to get some kind of results out actually
do you have a classification of the
institution of the classroom versus
industry is there an industrial
representation here are a selection if
you look in the paper this was one that
i took i wrote up for the common i
triple e software and I know and that's
in that paper we talked about how much
of them were industry and how many of
them were with students I can't remember
off hand I want to say it's maybe 5050
but that's a wild guess truly so okay
let me okay so anyway what I hope at
least I've given some examples that you
know through these empirical studies we
get some kind of useful insights that
you know can help us make useful
decisions in practice I think I've shown
for sure that abstracting conclusions
isn't straightforward is I can look at
the same studies and you know try and
say that this leads up to something but
at some point there's a judgment call in
here a lot of it has things to do with
the issues that were raised today and
how do I trust certain studies over
another do I care about students versus
industry and does the confidence
interval really indicate something or
does it just mean that there was truly
uh you know a large confidence interval
for that for that phenomenon alright
hopefully i showed the idea that the
going through these different studies
can actually help aid tech transfer you
know we've been working in a model for a
while now where we see university is a
laboratory for industry we try some of
these things out in the small you know
find out get the bugs worked out see if
there's really any promise to these
things and then you know do pilot
studies in industry with less risk than
if we just dumped some some new idea on
folks and i think we also need industry
for focusing on forgetting the
university studies actually focused on
things that can make a difference in the
field what was needed was a body of
knowledge yeah one study i think
not have given us you know much of a
sense that there's a real phenomenon out
there looking across several studies
however I think we can get at least a
sense like you said about whether things
line up and whether there's a
consistency in the answers you know and
there's a need to look at different
contexts to see if things really do vary
from from different types of studies in
different types of environments but it's
it's a long term process it's it's I
think you can see some of the challenges
now when we try and say that these are
results it should be really of interest
to the to the engineers that are in the
field actually applying some of these
techniques that we have a hard time
making the the transfer in a way
sometimes so some of the work that I've
been doing has really been focusing on
it well how do we support this process a
little better how can we communicate to
the customers that empirical study has a
role to play here you know that it says
something useful and so if the end what
I would like to do I know I'm running a
little late is just it's going to circle
back again and say well what if we
learned from all this what have we
learned from all these difficulties that
now we had to you know try and address
the DoD's concern about how do i put
together a system that can kind of
operationally help build up these values
of knowledge okay so this is a
collaboration that we've done at the
fraunhofer with a number of different
folks think that the primary one gju is
defense acquisition University which is
a university within the Defense
Department that teaches government folks
how to not only how to build systems and
software but actually how to manage the
acquisition of systems and software so
if my developer comes to me and says I'm
building your software for the next jet
fighter and we're doing x y&z you know
are those dangerous things if they say
they're doing pair programming for
example should I be concerned it should
I be happy you know that I'm getting
good benefit from my money and so that's
the audience that this is a publicly
open system by the way so it's something
that everyone can go to contribute to
take a look at but you know the primary
user is really these Defense Department
people that have to worry about very
deciding between techniques for building
software and systems what we did looking
at different practices
we started with with practices that are
recommended by government and industry
experts I mean obviously we're not going
to just throw everything into the
repository but coming back to these
ideas of trust ability and
contextualization you know we need to do
a little bit more the Defense Department
actually is awash in sites that you can
go to that says here's how you should
build systems here's how you should
build software we started off this work
by doing a little survey and you know
amazingly everyone had the same
complaints you know there's too many of
them they're all a bunch of experts
saying you should do it this way and I
don't know why I don't know if they fit
all the projects that i might work on
and so we've been trying to address this
a little bit better here you know for
all the four examples that I gave
earlier what we've tried to do trying to
do is really abstract at some level a
generic process of going through so I
have to figure out what's that what's
the topic you know what's the practice
I'm interested in I have to worry about
my search parameters and what kind of
evidence do I care about what sources
are going to include what measures am I
looking for I have to actually go out
and find the evidence you maybe by doing
a literature survey maybe by
interviewing practitioners in the field
to find out what they're doing yeah I
have to make decisions at each of these
steps let's just do I care about expert
opinion you know if an expert says that
they've been doing it this way and it's
better than doing it you know they've
been doing pair programming and it's
better than that you know is that
something that I care about if it's
someone with a lot of years experience I
don't want to throw that in LG way on
the other hand it's little bit hard to
figure out how I put it in with the rest
of my information okay somehow I have to
filter these things extract the content
you know so do some analysis of evidence
then I have to integrate it all in a way
that if practitioners can come take a
look at what's there and understand what
the bottom line is without having to
read all the different studies that are
out there in the field so to problems
that we came up with immediately one is
that you know as you can see i think
from any of the examples I showed you
know and those are some of the more
promising areas where I had a lot of
studies on those particular topics you
know for every particular practice
that's out there that I might want to
worry about I don't have a bunch of
studies already on it so I have to worry
about you know there since
studies on many topics already to allow
me to build the system and then secondly
you know that there's users out there in
the field that want this information now
they can't really wait for what could be
potentially a very long research project
in order to put out find the information
put it all together abstract the
conclusions and communicate it out again
so what we've done is come up with a bit
of a scheme behind it and you'll have to
bear with me I never found a good way to
really show you what the system is going
to look like if I showed your
screenshots as a bunch of pages with a
bunch of text on them it's not so
interesting so let me try and illustrate
the idea behind it and then I'll show
you some at the end to what you say that
it's really a real thing so back to that
idea of trust ability our hypothesis
here is that an educated guess is better
than not having any information at all
but I have to tell you that it's an
educated guess you know if I could show
you the results for prayer programming I
want you to believe that's a stronger
conclusion then coming back and telling
you which requirements elicitation
technique you should use because there I
don't have quite as much evidence or
evidence I can put together in such a
rigorous way so what we wanted to do was
cast the net wide allow all kinds of
evidence to come into this thing but put
a label on it so that you could see well
how much evidence is there and if I have
a threshold and I went to throw some
things away that's fine you can decide
you don't want to trust you no evidence
it's further than further down the case
so what we came up with it was a very
simple four step scale that talks about
things like well how was the practice
applied was it done in was it done once
in a classroom all the way up to has it
been done for many years on real
production projects okay so I give some
some amount of points based on that how
are they measured which goes from was it
somebody's opinion all the way up to you
know I have I'm a CMMI level 5 company
and I have all the reams of data i can
show you if you really care about it
yeah how was it reported it was a you
know an anecdote that I've heard was it
an interview we did someone all the way
up to its been through peer review and
it's out there in tsc and then finally
who reported it you know was it someone
a university professor he didn't really
have insight into what the team was
actually doing or was it someone on that
that engineering team that actually was
applying the things you know again is
there a magic behind this video is there
a really rigorous way we can defend this
snow is it's really a bit of a
subjective scale we started out looking
at the medical literature yeah where
they've worried a lot about how I put
together a lot of different medical
studies and bless their hearts they can
ask questions like you know what was the
level of statistical significance and
you know what two level of them accuracy
where the measurements reported I mean
they're so far beyond what's in the
software engineering literature so we
did have to kind of scale ourselves back
and find ourselves into a position we
can try and deal with things and
separate useful things out what we use
this for is that then I could come in
and say well here's a labar going from
zero completely untrustable evidence up
to you know 20 points is the maximum so
very highly trusted weapons I can show
you for a given practice how much
evidence we have about it so here i
think we had like this is formal
inspections looks like so we had maybe
12 pieces of evidence here and i can
show you where on the scale they fall so
the idea is you get a little bit of a
clearly we need to work with the user
interface expert by the way but you can
see here that i get at least a sense
about where's the evidence you how much
do I really know about this particular
practice and I can differentiate
something that's fairly mature like
inspections where things tend to
congregate down this end from something
like maybe scrum let's say you know
where we have a lot of things down here
in the more anecdotal wind what we're
trying to do with this is to kind of
convince people you know we make the
scale we publish that out there so I
understand where these numbers are
coming from trying to get people to
think about well how can I get further
up if I have a very weak piece of
evidence well what can I do to make it
better see I can collect more rigorous
measures I can go through peer review
you know there's get people thinking
about what makes good evidence and what
engineers can use here's a little bit so
if I'm like a practitioner then wanting
to take some action the ideas that I
could
and see Oh pair programming you know i
would i would at least understand that
you know some stuff has been done and
it's made even you know at least if i'm
evaluating like different techniques
I've seen this I could say oh there's
there seems to be a lot more evidence in
this area exact but then when it comes
to circles the particular actions I take
I still have yes there's still a lot of
decisions exact so these are like this
is like at a macro level like yeah like
subject a not do i do a versus being but
not necessarily how i do it exactly
exactly so there's a exactly right so
there's really two dimensions and they
be how to or you know what it really
means for me i'll get to in just a
second but this is like you said exactly
just is just to let me come and get a
sense about what we'd also like to do is
get some of the things you're coming out
of the excuse me out of the research
labs you know so i might come and see a
practice where I just have one little
piece of evidence here it might be
really promising but you know I better
go into it with my eyes open saying
Jesus not a lot of real experience here
yet have you actually built up I mean I
mean it seems valuable that as we're
maturing as a disappointment but it
seems like like how do you get this
database populated right i mean
wikipedia has this great effect lorina
people like like to write about their
subjects but how do you how do you get
people actually Jesus any kinda me Jules
yes well we just went live with it
actually in January this year and what
we're in the so kind of working behind
the scenes I think we have want to say
about like 40 practices and hundred
pieces of evidence so you can see you
know some of these have a lot and then
you have a lot where we don't have very
much evidence at all yet and what we're
trying to do our starting just a little
bit how it you know what we're
collecting but we're trying to get some
of that Wikipedia effect actually you
know we're trying to get a user
community where people can come in and
say you know the evidence you have is
wrong yeah I used it here's what it did
people can be anonymous it is exactly
this is not just being on the web oh yes
I'm sorry you're actually
you're actually soliciting input people
can change it yes exactly just anybody
can come in from outside anybody can
come in and submit and then there's we
have a team on the inside kind of it
processes things really what we do is if
something comes in we send it off to a
subject matter expert in the area and
then they look at it and say yes exactly
so it's kind of a year we try and catch
some of the Wikipedia wit you know in
heaven obviously we had visions let's
say oh that would being a lot more open
and community organized in the beginning
and that doesn't work so well with the
to your team environment necessarily so
I still don't quite understand this
approach so I don't quite understand how
how 12 different experiences can be put
on the same scale in that each
experience might represent a different
claim about whatever the subject is
right right so you know one might just
be that au pair programming is better
than not and the other one might be that
pair programming gives you a 17-percent
productivity boots to a third one might
be that au pair programming gives you a
23-percent quality right exactly so so I
don't understand how those can all be
accumulating over once they're not so
this this is like I said this is just
one dimension it kind of gives me a
sense of what you know how you know
there's a there's a summary that pulls
that part together that i'll get to in
just a second and this just tells me a
little bit about how much do we really
know yeah about what goes into that the
scale would be attached to a sentence or
something right that makes them clean
right right so so we're no I'm saying
where's that claim come from well this
is this would be attached to a whole
practice it just says how much do we
really know about pair programming how
much do we really know about formal
inspections the you just skip ahead here
and this is the part where gets a little
cartoony so bear with me but what we're
really doing is we have the data
structure for each piece of evidence we
come in and what I was trying to show
here with my icons is that some of this
might be you know something from the
literature you know someone's published
and said we use this particular
technique some of these might be
interviews we've done with folks in the
field where we can go solicit things
some of these are DoD guidebooks you
know let's say this is a practice you
should be doing what we have we
much more than three fields but they're
all grouped together and to tell me
something about the source so is this a
published paper has it been
peer-reviewed how do i how much trust do
I have in the the publication itself the
context yeah so have you was this a coal
odic located team or one that was
distributed all over listed a fixed-wing
aircraft or a business system and then
what the results were and as you said
everyone's going to what we do is just
collect text and we try and accumulate
it into three buckets cost quality
schedule so like you said for each of
these you know maybe this one says pair
programming with seventeen percent
better than they're not this one might
just say geez we've been doing pair
programming for a while and we swear by
it we think it's much better than the
other approach so there's specific
things here where each piece of evidence
goes into one of these templates you
know we extract the pieces that were
interested in particularly and then we
have a rating scale so i could say well
for this practice who might just have
bronze level information and we only
have the evidence there yet when we get
to a sufficient point where we have
enough evidence I'm sorry one of the
subject matter experts gets and the job
of pulling it all together and again we
had to do it textually as much as we
would have loved to do something numeric
you know the examples I tried to show
words we're saying for many practices we
just don't have that out there yet so
some expert writes a summary that says
well where have we seen it being used
maybe it's only been used on large
projects but not small ones for example
what kind of benefits have we seen and
again these have to be broken down by
well we always saw a benefit on large
large systems but for small ones it was
too much overhead it wasn't really
worthwhile and how do I get started with
it and then we even pointers down to
these guys so if I'm really interested I
can get some information on demand for
example you know I might only be worried
about this context this whole this is
might be the only one that matches mine
so I might want to look at this paper or
at least what I've extracted from it and
ignore those other three things okay but
again we also have the trouble of you
know a lot of subject matter experts can
make a good story through the evidence
but how do I have any kind of confidence
in it so again our gold level forgetting
the content there is to send this off to
basically be peer-reviewed
so we have other experts from government
industry academia that will then vet the
information you have the ability to say
things like jeezy it's a nice story but
you know you only talk to people that
are really advocates of this thing you
know you better go yeah I know other
people have had negative results with it
you better get their input too okay or
you know Jesus what you said is true but
you know your wrote a book and no no
engineers ever going to have time to
read it also can we cut it back a little
bit okay so we do have kind of an
internal feedback on the quality there
also and then just to point out that as
we're building it kind of bottom-up you
know I accumulate the evidence I try and
put it together by some subject matter
expert users are really coming in from
the top down so they'll do a query on
the interface that might say I'm looking
for practices that reduce schedule they
get directed to whatever practice this
might be then I might say gee I'm lonely
I'm on a safety-critical program I don't
really care if they've used it in
academia so show me what kind of
evidence comes from safety critical
programs so i can see the template and
if i really want to i could go read the
paper you know or see the whole
interview with my one so the idea of
kind of you only have to drill down and
see as much information as you're really
interested in particularly by ciba
tightening how many different attributes
do we use there well some of this when i
pull together the information that says
what do we know about the cost quality
schedule that's more of a narrative
based information for each piece of
evidence we have a set of metadata you
know that says things like my what's the
domain was a government was an industry
was it academia try thinking there's a
ten fields all together and I can't of
course I just went blank but but each of
those has a set of predefined values and
so I basically select them here and then
at this level I can tell you it's only
been used in government it's only been
used in industry something like that
semantic level somehow you're creating a
little bit of an ontology in this area I
guess my main concern is like do we
really have enough data is there enough
I mean how long I mean how get are the
other maybe more positively how how big
a project is this how do you know what
you've done of course people are always
doing new studies but but still you can
look back on and say you know it took so
many years for us to in the Artic us so
long to index the web yes Google I mean
given like all the knowledge we have
up-to-date now how much effort would it
really take to build this pathology yeah
so there's there's two interesting
questions or when is the point you made
about semantic web for example that's
something that we would like to I think
as we get a little bit more mature here
we would like to work with folks that
are doing research in that area and to
see if they can help us automate some of
this to help see if we can learn things
the other question about how much work
is it I think you could spend a lifetime
on it truthfully and so what we're doing
is trying to we have a user advisory
group so we meet with them periodically
and say give us you know for practice
areas we can get our arms around so
those things say things like risk
management trying to think of the top
ones risk management requirements
engineering so we're at least trying to
look within smaller sets of things
rather than get the whole universe and
put it in here right now so anyway
here's it now that you've borne through
the cartoons here's just a screenshot
that says you know Jesus is the sushi
actually a real system if you like you
can go take a look at it people always
forget the s for whatever reason it's an
HTTPS address but you can go there take
a look play around go browse and we'd be
thrilled I think to get input from
anyone in this room actually as we go
forward I think that you know so there's
technical decisions we've made based on
the evidence out there and how hard or
difficult it will be to put it together
in a meaningful way I think what we
really need to worry about now is not so
much technical issues as collaborative
ones you know we really need to grow
this community of subject matter experts
like you said we need to really I think
to be
successful at all we need to get get
some of that same community spirit for
example that infuses Wikipedia and we
need to put people to put things in I
need people that not be afraid about
saying you know that's a load of
whatever you know here's my experience
it's completely different from what you
have there so far ah that's that's one
of the things that worry is this
actually I think that um at least we can
try and address that somewhat by asking
people or what yeah what's your evidence
yeah part of the decision can be made
based on how many and how much of the
how much can create information they can
actually put into the evidence fields if
you will you try it now we haven't
actually gotten through so many well you
know the idea of having each of the
practice things being reviewed by a by
an outside objective team we haven't
done so many of those yet the ones that
we've done have been fairly
collaborative I guess I think as we get
to some of the more contentious topics I
think they'll be a little bit more you
know just agreement back and forth and
so that's I think that's something we
just have to kind of play with and see
how it goes as we get there but that's a
good point it's a little bit of a
feedback loop problem as well in that
you know if if I'm a user of this thing
I'll go in and I'm going to want to do
the practices that have the best
evidence associated with it right so
therefore I go and I do it and now I
have experienced and I enter my
experience into the system under that
which piles up even more evidence in
favor of that thing so the things that
start out with the most initial evidence
are going to get my most evidence
because people are going to hit there
and the things that are maybe way better
yeah like much bigger improvements in
quality or productivity or whatever but
maybe don't have as much evidence people
will shy away from right so it'll be
harder for new things and a break in
because there's this feedback that's it
that's a very interesting idea i hadn't
should be truthful I actually I get
maybe more hopeful you know but then
saying I have a real rigorous way for
saying this but I've been hopeful that
if we can put out some of the things
that come out of the labs you know that
there's a class of early adopters out
there that are going to say even though
there's not a lot of evidence that
sounds really nifty to me I'm hoping
that we can actually there's
stakeholders in this also you know if
I'm a researcher in a lab and I come up
with a new approach to testing let's say
and I put it out there I have an
incentive to go out and try and get it
into work and when I do case studies
you'll put them back in there you know
so we're hoping to get a little bit of
competition between some of the
stakeholders in this to help drive put
the practices together but yeah but as
you said you know it's very hard to kind
of predict how the community is going to
go with this and so will I'm looking
forward to it though but we'll see we
were involved not with CMU but we we
were talking to SDI a lot in the
beginning SC I is kind of an opera
opposite point of view or they really do
more of a kind of a mode where they make
the decisions then kind of push it out
to the community so I think there's a
lot of their advice that they give that
we can collect evidence on you know and
try and build up in here also in terms
of a collaborative workspace so I think
they were anxious to play along and have
some control over what we're saying
about some of their techniques but they
weren't going to put a lot of resources
into helping us build it so these kinds
of things would be to beat it already
yes oh yes exactly and I should say to
that it's not really as much a
standalone system as I may have just
made it sound but the defense university
has a large set of interconnected
resources you know where we're going to
be a plug-in I guess to the rest of this
collaborative workspace they have so in
a way it's not like we're starting with
our three folks and saying okay let's
build a huge community but they're you
know they're our discussion groups and
forums and people that are interested in
these types of issues already out there
but I hope we're going to help us build
this
okay great Oh so anyway just to just to
sum up so as an empirical software
engineer I like to think we have good
examples of how the the field has
matured as somebody said of how we've
been using measurement to try to drive
good ideas into practice and do it in a
controlled way without the risk of
taking something you know brand new and
just dropping it out there into an
industry engineering team you know I
think I've also try at least try to make
the argument that you're having a single
study or a single piece of evidence on
some of these decisions is not really
what we needed in order to be convincing
to the engineers that we need to work
with in order to convince people to try
and adopt some of the new technologies
that are coming out so you know I think
that as we go forward not only do we
have the challenge of doing good studies
and continuing to build the field that
way but more importantly in some ways I
think we have the challenge of really
communicating the results in a good way
to the engineers and the people in the
field that should be making decisions I
hope based on some of these things you
know study is perfect there's always
going to be the the problem that we're
dealing with human subjects that we have
a limited amount of control over some of
the things we're trying to study but I
think that by really having a good
dialogue and a rational discussion about
these things we can try and make it you
know clear what is the real benefits of
these studies and I don't know that
there's much of a reason for doing these
studies if we're not trying to have some
kind of impact on on industry and
practitioners so time will tell and
whether or not this particular
Clearinghouse approaches is workable and
useful but if nothing else I would look
forward to coming back in a few years
and letting you know I'll either have
some great success stories or some
interesting lessons from the field
without what we did wrong and what we
want to do right the next time so thank
you for your attention any last
questions
okay great thank you